many military leaders have asked many
people I know you know and I've gotten
the question myself
is this the hill that you want to die on
and those leaders asking that question
they will never find that Hill
if this is not it they will never find
that Hill
yeah yeah if if this ain't that if coven
doesn't reveal all of these Hills and
the need to protect them I don't know
what does it seems that clear Jordan go
on yeah I've been asked that same
question and you know I think a question
that I have and that many military
members have is where is the moral
courage of our Commanders
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast this is the second in a series
of interviews with military
whistleblowers who have faced mandates
and various kinds of punishment and
retribution for resisting them I have
with me today Jordan Carr and Grant
Smith they're going to tell you who they
are and what they've faced and then we
are going to explore the many issues
that are connected to these mandates and
the Very courageous resistance to them
that members of the military are showing
so Grant Jordan welcome to Darkhorse
um Jordan do you want to start by
telling us
um who you are what role you played in
the military and and what has happened
to you
yes thank you
thank you Jordan Carr I am a former
United States Air Force intelligence
officer I spent nine years in the United
States Air Force and I was discharged on
May 1st 2022
um over these coveted vaccine mandates
and and we'll get into a little bit more
of that later on but I come from a
family of service members multiple
generations of my family have served
this country or are currently serving
this country
um and like a lot of service members you
know we love this country we love the
Constitution and we want to continue to
serve our country
excellent uh Grant how about you
first of all thanks for having us Brett
uh my name is Grant Smith I am still on
active duty so I'll start off by just
saying that all these thoughts and
opinions that I'm going to be sharing
today are my own and don't reflect those
of the dod or departmental Army
uh I was an infantryman and have since
become a physical therapist at the
beginning of uh covid I was a brigade
physical therapist and I've since
transitioned to being a division
holistic health and fitness officer I'm
the holistic health and fitness program
and the Army is a new program
uh that is based on a field manual that
replaced the old physical Readiness
training manual a couple years ago and I
think it's a great framework and I think
we can use that framework to to talk
about these issues and that's one of the
main reasons that I'm here today let's
talk about that
excellent um let me ask you a question
it's a clarifying question holistic is
one of these words that if well used I
love it and if abused it causes me to uh
to shudder I assume that in this case
holistic just simply means that you're
taking a broader view of human
well-being that doesn't isolate
particular systems but recognizes that
you have all of these systems uh
interrelated with each other and
interacting and um is that somewhere in
the ballpark exactly Brad it's the
opposite of myopic you know we have
these different facets of health and
fitness and the holistic approach is
just recognizing that they're
interdependent
excellent yes Heather and I
um when we see errors that people make
where they've isolated something and
then discovered that when you isolate
that thing and try to improve something
something much worse goes wrong yeah our
our response is well welcome to complex
systems in our book Heather and I
discussed the danger of hyper novelty
which is making modern people sick both
physically and psychologically
two of the most common disorders are
anxiety and depression our first sponsor
mind Bloom is a leader in the treatment
of anxiety and depression using at-home
ketamine therapy it is a combination of
science-backed Medicine with clinician
guidance and support for people looking
to improve mental health and increase
their sense of well-being
mind Bloom connects patients to licensed
psychiatric professionals to help them
achieve better outcomes with lower costs
greater convenience and an artfully
crafted experience
to begin take mind Bloom's online
assessment and schedule a video consult
with a licensed clinician to determine
if mind Bloom is right for you
if approved you'll discuss your health
history and goals for mental health
treatment with your clinician to tailor
your mind Bloom regimen
mind Bloom will send you a kit in the
mail complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience
after only two sessions 87 percent of
Mind Bloom clients reported improvements
in depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety
it's time to enter the next chapter of
mental health and well-being let mind
Bloom guide you
right now mind Bloom is offering our
listeners a hundred dollars off your
first six session program when you sign
up at mindbloom.com Darkhorse and use
promo code Darkhorse at checkout go to
mindbloom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com Darkhorse promo code
Darkhorse
our second sponsor for this episode is
MD hearing aid
MD hearing aid was founded by an ENT
surgeon who made it his mission to
develop quality hearing aid that anyone
could afford
recognizing that about 95 percent of
people who need a hearing aid only
require a few settings he removed some
of the less often needed components
he also cut out the middleman and now MD
hearing aid makes a rechargeable hearing
aid that is FDA registered and costs a
small fraction of what typical hearing
aids cost
these hearing aids aim to fit so well
that no one will know you're wearing
them the rechargeable batteries last up
to 30 hours their volt plus model is
water resistant and up to three feet of
water and you don't need a prescription
to get one you buy it directly from the
source where audiologists and licensed
hearing Specialists are available seven
days a week
everyone can empathize with what it
feels like to be left out of a
conversation that others are enjoying
here's a testimonial from a friend who
has substantial hearing loss and relies
on hearing aids I asked her to try this
product and here's what she said
with my particular type of hearing loss
a deep male voice in a noisy room is the
hardest situation for me to hear and
understand speech I wore the MD hearing
aid to have a conversation with a deep
voice man in a room with a lot of white
noise the MD hearing aid passed the test
my conversation partner's voice was
clear and understandable
at a price point of under a thousand
dollars I was amazed at how effective
they are
MD hearing aid has brought affordable
hearing to over 600 000 satisfied
customers plus they offer a 45-day
risk-free trial with 100 money back
guarantee
at Clinic level care for 80 percent less
with MD hearing aid go to
mdhearingaid.com and use the promo code
Darkhorse to get their new buy one get
one deal a pair of hearing aids cost
just
149.99 plus Dark Horse listeners receive
a free extra charge case a hundred
dollar value
so head to mdhearingaid.com and use
promo code Darkhorse to get their new
buy one get one deal a pair of hearing
aids for only 149.99
right you can't treat a human being as
an isolated series of systems it doesn't
work the same thing can be said for uh
for for governance right we have to
recognize that there are always
unintended consequences and and be
mindful of that and in fact that is a uh
a highly resonant theme with respect to
what has taken place both with the
apparent uh human meddling that produced
covet in the first place
um to our
remarkably jaw-droppingly inept at best
response to the spread of covid which of
course
as those who viewed the first episode of
um of discussions with military
whistleblowers
um is is
part and parcel of what we're facing
that although the military the uh the
mandates have largely been lifted for
the civilian population
um in effect as a result of successful
pushback
by many of us the military retains a
commitment to these mandates I know that
courts have enjoined that is to say
suspended the mandates in some branches
of the military and not others can
either of you shed light on what the
current state of mandates is
yeah I can touch on that uh the other
branches of service uh in the military
other than the Army have injunctions
uh my my position is that the armies
kind of played it smart with respect to
evaluating religious accommodation
requests and that they took a very long
time to do so for example I had mine
submitted in November of 2021 and just
got back my denial about a month ago and
when your request for accommodation is
denied in each branch of service you get
an opportunity to appeal and so it looks
like
the duration of that process in the Army
is close to a year
for the initial denial to come back and
the other branch is a service that
happened much more quickly which
required or gave courts justification to
intervene to provide temporary
injunctions to provide relief given that
there is evidence
the legal process required for
evaluating someone's request for
religious accommodation we're not being
adhered to in those branches of service
interesting so you have a very long
process and courts have intervened the
none of the branches I take it have
relented but courts have forced them uh
not to apply mandates and sounds like
most of these cases
I I will say that there is a a part of
this whole story that just cannot help
but evoke Catch-22 right the idea that a
religious exemption would take uh a year
to work its way through this process I
mean it should be a fairly simple matter
especially if as I understand it the
legal standard is is your religious
belief earnestly held and beyond that
the content of the belief is irrelevant
so whatever the assessment is about
whether or not you're telling it like it
is with respect to what you believe that
should be exempting you it shouldn't be
a very complicated process for them to
figure out whether you've met the
standard or not and yet something so
utterly bureaucratic has taken over that
there's a year-long process involved is
that what I'm understanding
so it's not it's not exactly that the
process takes that long and you know I'm
not an attorney so you know keep that in
mind
but my understanding is that
you can have a sincere belief and the
government's not necessarily required to
provide you with accommodation so long
as they can meet the strict scrutiny
standard which is that they can prove
you know there's a grave risk of serious
harm if they grant that accommodation
and so uh the evidentiary basis for this
in the case of covid is just
non-existent the government does not
have evidence that providing somebody an
accommodation to forego covid-19
vaccination
constitutes a grave risk of serious harm
if they had such evidence they would
have provided it and we could go down
that rabbit hole perhaps at some point
in this conversation down the road
but my assertion is that they don't have
such evidence and since they don't have
such evidence denying them very quickly
puts the courts in a position where they
can evaluate that or the courts can say
hey DOD what's your evidence that this
is a this is the least restrictive means
but vaccination is the least restrictive
means of allowing somebody to continue
to serve uh and in those cases and those
other branches of service that's why we
have those injunctions because the dod
has not provided that data so I I
speculate that the reason that the
Army's taking so long
is to forestall uh litigation and Forest
all courts intervening but as we proceed
and I will tell you that shortly after
the latest injunction was provided in
the Marine Corps within about two weeks
is when I got my initial denial back so
I do believe that the things are those
two things are connected and I think
that the Army made the determination you
know hey you know an injunction is going
to come eventually for us not taking
action on these so let's go ahead and
just deny them and uh get this process
started interesting so I did not know
that the grave risk standard it does
seem to me that this is you know a uh
I'm struggling for a word other than
marvelous but it's a marvelous test case
here because
that standard fails on multiple obvious
grounds
right if the idea is that there's a
grave risk then the implication is that
these remedies these things that are
falsely called vaccines
would you know prevent transmission or
contraction of the disease right that
would be the basis on which you would be
compelled in which your objection would
be overwritten but in this case
these uh inoculations do not prevent
contraction or transmission what's more
um I'm just gonna guess by the fact that
you're in the military and by how you
appear that you're young and healthy and
so the idea that this is somehow
essential
is preposterous because if there's one
thing that we have learned over the
course of covid it's that young healthy
people are actually in an excellent
position to fend off covid through
innate and natural immunity and so the
idea that your objection must be
overridden because of a grave risk is
just it's multiply preposterous
you know Brett just to add something on
that you you said that you know there's
not evidence that it prevents
transmission but in fact my denial level
from the Army Surgeon General did
specifically state that the reason that
it was the least restrictive means was
for me to become vaccinated was to
protect other other soldiers you know
that was explicitly stated in my denial
memo and many other denial memos that
have been shared with me so uh they are
taking the position still
um at this stage that these vaccinations
prevent infection and transmission and I
can tell you that the data doesn't
support that within the dod from what
I'm aware and I agree with with your
assessment of uh the situation it
absolutely does not
um support it that would be true even if
there were no known harm to these things
but the idea that we're going to expose
people to a risk from the inoculations
themselves when they have mechanisms
that do successfully fend off covid and
do successfully generate much more
robust immunity than the shots
themselves is the height of preposterous
and it's as if
the dod is responding to some fantasy
narrative that just has no obligation to
meet any evidentiary standard right
right even if we didn't know these
things at the beginning we sure as heck
know him now and the idea that the
mandates have not been backed off in
light of what we have learned about the
ineffectiveness and Hazard of these
vaccines is
um it's it's Unthinkable it's
Unthinkable that we would expose people
um to these products and it it raises
you know as as I keep saying on the Dark
Horse podcast and as I said in the first
of these uh these discussions with um
with military folks
this goes straight to the heart of
Nuremberg and it does so twice over
in the sense that one Nuremberg
established that we have a right to
informed consent that is to say we have
a right to know what it is that we are
being treated with and to say yes I will
accept the risks that come along with it
and we are not being well informed and
we are not being allowed to give our
consent we are being strong armed with
these things the military more than the
rest of us
um and the second way in which this is a
violation of Nuremberg is that Nuremberg
established uh that the highest
principle is not the chain of command
the highest principle is that when
immoral orders flow down the chain of
command one is obligated to refuse them
and the idea that we are going to punish
people who have refused
for very good reason
um is let's just say it is alarming to
say the least if you understand why the
world went through the exercise of the
trials at Nuremberg and the writing of
the code at Nuremberg then you know when
we start violating those principles
something terrible is uh is afoot
now Jordan I know
um
you have uh
a closer relationship to the questions
of Nuremberg than uh really I think
uh well with one exception maybe anybody
I've met so do you want to talk to us a
little bit about
your history
yes right so um first of all I do want
to point out that you know the oath of
office for officers is different than
the oath of enlistment for enlisted
members and for officers our oath you
know the Constitution is
um really what we base everything off of
um regardless of rank regardless of
person regardless of chain of command
every single officer has an obligation
to put the Constitution
um above all else
um and so every single officer who has
been complicit in passing down these
unlawful orders
um they're part of this we have an
obligation to not obey unlawful orders
and moral orders and I have a family
Legacy of you know my my mother served
in the United States military but her
mother was German her oppa was in the
German military leading up to World War
II
um and he saw what was going on kind of
similar to to you know what's occurring
throughout the world today is you know
more and more we're giving up our
freedoms and people say you know how
could the Holocaust have happened how
could nobody have done anything about it
um in the same way that we're allowing
you know the government to dictate you
know our livelihoods and our jobs
um they're telling us that in order to
make a living
um to to earn a paycheck that we have to
put something in our body that we do not
want
um and so my great oppa saw what was
going on in Germany and he said I'm not
going to I'm not going to participate in
this and so he you know he was very
wealthy my only family was very wealthy
um and the German military imprisoned
him
um during World War II because he
wouldn't carry out the Nazis orders
um and I'm very proud of that Legacy
because I see what's going on today and
I'm proud to stand up you know against
tyranny today within the military now
outside of the military and you know he
almost died in prison and then after the
war they lost everything I mean they
lost
um the Germans completely ransacked
their house
um but of course it was nothing compared
to what what the true victims of the
Holocaust experienced but I am proud to
come from a family Legacy that says you
know we're not going to be complicit
we're not going to turn a blind eye and
so I think that's something that people
need to realize is you know it's never
too late to do the right thing and at
this point there's so much evidence
and there's been so much litigation
demonstrating how unlawful all this has
been
um and I My Hope Is that people can now
see you know what the government has
done what these unelected entities have
done
um and how much power we the people have
allowed them to have by not standing up
and so you know I do see parallels
between this and this message is really
for all the Military Officers all the
commanders it's not too late to stand up
and to say this was wrong and to make
remedies for for what's you know
occurred
it is never too late it is never too
late it is always at whatever point you
realize that immoral orders are being
handed down it is never too late to
resist them and I will say
um I do not come from a military family
um but uh I am Jewish and I was raised
by Elders who made very certain that
that I and my brother understood
what had taken place and that in fact no
one anywhere is safe from this kind of
process that something takes a hold of a
population and
we knew it could happen here I did not
think that I would live to see it but I
don't think you are
in any way exaggerating the relationship
between these we are we are looking at
immoral orders we are watching people
accept them because not accepting them
is very difficult
I have to say hearing your description
of your great grandfather's
resistance and the idea that he was
imprisoned over it the idea that your
your family lost what they had which was
apparently quite substantial that does
suggest a kind of
um
Integrity that was not commonly seen the
willingness to give up things because
what you've what you're being told to do
is simply wrong when it would obviously
be easier just to go along with it and
rationalize it that is what
we all must do
and very few find the courage to do and
I I find something very hopeful in the
fact that um
uh you are you are Generations apart
from your great grandfather continuing
um his legacy of of resistance of that
of that very pattern so um
uh words are inadequate but
um thank you and and thank him for for
standing up it is uh it is the morally
right thing to do and
um I don't think people appreciate how
difficult it is
right and I and I think um you know
there are parallels to to those standing
up today
um
I've
heard from so many people who have lost
their jobs they've lost their health
care
um for doing the morally right thing for
not obeying these unlawful orders and so
you know there's been over 7 700
military members involuntarily
discharged from service over this and
you know they've stood up for their for
the Constitution they've stood up for
um really the right thing to do
um and they've lost pretty much
everything I mean some of these people
can't find a job because they have a
discharge characterization that is less
than honorable
um and so you know I hope that those
people know that that there's hope
um America has a way of writing wrongs
um and we're not going to stop fighting
uh I I resonate with that wholeheartedly
I would also say
you know one of the one of the difficult
things for me growing up in grappling
you know I I thought as a child that I
was you know distant in history from the
Holocaust in World War II I realize now
that that was a child's error right it
was I was born 25 years after its end
um
and so these things were very much alive
and well uh in in our minds but still
understanding how it could have happened
was difficult and in fact has remained
difficult for me until
covet
until I saw these processes unfold in
front of me until I saw people say
things that every reasonable human
should know are false but say them with
apparently complete conviction
and the other thing that that comes from
your story
that I think helps explain the
curiousness of the spasm of genocidal
authoritarianism that that the Holocaust
represents is the way in which
punishment is used to alter belief
that is to say you know we look at the
Nazis and we think how could anybody
have said these things do they hear
themselves what we don't quite
understand is that hierarchies in which
um reward and Punishment flow are very
natural to human beings and when the
thing that controls those hierarchies is
intent on moving in a direction that all
reasonable people would understand is a
violation of our most uh fundamental
values they can accomplish it by making
the recognition of that violation
incredibly expensive and so what I'm
getting at is I'm looking at a medical
establishment in which almost every
doctor has been drafted into something
you know I'm not a religious person but
I would I I do think it Unholy is almost
the only term for it right when when the
entire medical establishment is
recommending treatments that are at the
very least so new and so radical that we
couldn't possibly know how dangerous
they are and they are doing so and
assuring people that they are safe even
as the evidence mounts that that is not
remotely the case what has happened how
could all doctors be participating in
this with very few exceptions and the
answer is
at every stage the corruption of their
their values and their their
relationship to the oath that they took
when they signed up for their profession
is eroded right that is to say the
compromises are each small and in the
aggregate they are gigantic and
um
maybe maybe what I didn't learn as a
young person was that the resisting of
or immoral orders is more difficult than
you think because they don't come all at
once and by the time people hear an
order that they know for sure is immoral
they've lost the ability to assess it
because they've done things along the
way
so uh among other things these
discussions
um are filling in pieces of the puzzle
that I think are
um essential if we are to avoid adding
another tragedy to the terrible list of
tragedies of history of which the
Holocaust is is obviously a part
so Brett you said something about the
no reasonable person
you know would would be put in a
position and I think that that's that's
half of it I'm a big fan of Robert
Barnes who I know you've talked to
and he says motivation is the master of
reason
and so you know you have
people that are are engaging in
preference falsification or they know
that
hey you know Pfizer's randomized
controlled trial there were problems
with it and they kind of just keep that
to themselves but you also have people
that are able to make themselves believe
because the incentives align such that
they're incredibly motivated to believe
and so I do think that there are a
tremendous number of people that are
true believers that to this day believe
that the vaccines prevent transmission
infection and I think that that's the
underlying psychological mechanism is uh
just confirmation bias and motivated
reasoning yes and then there's another
piece to that puzzle isn't there because
um at the point that somebody because
the it is in
if you let's say make the error of
underrating the hazard of these
treatments
and so you think okay
they're not as safe as I was told they
don't really do what I was told they did
but they're not that bad I'm very likely
to get away with it if I get one if
that's the mistake you make and then
somebody approaches you with evidence
and says actually
you know for every case of myocarditis
that's bad enough for it to show up in a
doctor's office and get written down in
a chart there are destined to be cases
that are subclinical and those cases May
well shorten lives we may never know
which lives have been shortened but
actually getting away with it isn't the
it's not like if two weeks after you're
shot you haven't seen a symptom you
necessarily had no harm we just don't
know if you say that and the problem is
having accepted these things creates an
incentive to
um to silence the person delivering the
unwelcome message
especially if you've signed up for one
of these shots and so the sense is oh
damn I don't really want to walk around
thinking I'm a ticking Time Bomb
so the easiest way not to have that
thought is to imagine that there's
something desperately wrong with the
person trying to tell you
um there may be no level of safety for
anybody with these things
so I agree with you motivated reasoning
is at the heart of this but the uh the
shocking lesson is really
that it plays out in things like
personal attacks right rather than
process this piece of analysis I might
go after somebody who's trying to
deliver it right I might try to do away
with the messenger so that the analysis
doesn't arrive and
um
I think that's been the experience for
many of us who have tried to deliver
that message
um is that
people don't want to hear it they don't
they don't want the truth because they
feel
um
I think they acutely feel the hazard
that it puts them to psychologically
comfortable lies
performance painful truth
yeah and I think also a lot of people
don't want to believe that the
government and these entities you know
could have done this to them I'm vaccine
injured as a child and to this day my
mom you know says how could I have been
so ignorant to allow you to get this
when there was no reason for you to get
it and so you know I think that people
need to focus on the fact that we were
lied to you know the FDA the CDC our own
government lied to us and so I think
some people you know they don't want to
believe this you know ignorance is bliss
um and also it comes with
self-reflection right like can you look
yourself in the in the mirror and say
um you know how did I give up my
Integrity in believing the government
and you don't have to be religious to
understand that the government is trying
to play God and and I think that a lot
of people were fooled
um and that's another aspect of this is
that you know we want to believe that we
can trust our own government we want to
believe that that our government in the
United States of American government has
our best interests at heart and so you
know it is very
um disconcerting when you wake up and
understand no this is a money making
machine
um big Pharma is very much getting
profits from this our representatives
are getting profits from this
um and so I think when you when you
really look into this and you see that
we were all deceived that's when people
I think can can start coming together
and saying look like I was you know I
really thought that I was doing the
right thing I thought that I was doing
this to protect my family to protect my
neighbor and we were lied to
I think this is a a hugely important
point and there is I think there is a a
character difference
um that
uh is at the heart of who ends up on
which side of this issue
those of us who however it manages to be
true are comfortable recognizing when
we've gotten something wrong
um
the evidence is incontrovertible
people who tend to rationalize having
been wrong
so that they don't have to face the
mental consequences of it get stuck in
this cycle and I will say you know I've
been I've been
alarmed by at first the story of covet
itself and then the story of
um the the remedies and preventions that
we were faced with
for a long time and I've watched I've
watched how people behave and many of
the people who have shined in this
moment right the whistleblowers the
doctors who have stood up uh Robert
Malone uh who is a key inventor of core
technology in the MRNA vaccines who has
stood up many of these people are
themselves coveted vaccinated
and what that means is that at first
they bought it too at some level right
either they thought it was less
dangerous than it was or they thought it
was going to be more useful than it was
but they they had the kind of character
that upon discovering that the evidence
didn't meet what they had thought said
well okay that was an error and what I
would say to those listening to this
podcast is
I promise you if you find that feature
of your character where you become you
know nobody likes having been wrong it's
a painful experience but if you run from
it you will be wronger
and you will stay longer and that pain
will linger if you realize that the best
thing you can do is always as quickly as
you discover that you're wrong
acknowledge it and pay the price up
front of acknowledging it the price over
the course of your life is just that
much lower and frankly in this case your
your safety is that much greater the
safety of your family will be that much
greater if you just
as soon as the evidence tells a clear
story you recognize you know what I
called that one wrong I maybe I know
where my error was maybe I don't but I'm
happier to just have the debt paid yeah
I I hope people will look for that on
themselves because if they do a lot more
people will join us because frankly the
evidence really isn't ambiguous at this
point
I think that's an important Point Brett
about character we talk about character
a lot in the military
and uh frankly I don't think civilians
understand
fully why it's so important
at the end of the day we're a
bureaucracy you know we don't have
profit and loss mechanisms to organize
what we do we have commanders at every
Echelon that are often required to
self-certify things so to give you the
most straightforward example in the Army
at the company level
and which is the lowest level of command
we have a mission essential tasks that
if you're able to do these tasks hey
guess what you're ready to go to war
and it is up to company commanders to
certify what level of training they're
at and those tasks
and nobody can come in and tell them
they're wrong it does get checked in a
way at uh training rotations
but at the end of the day if that
Commander says hey we are trained we are
good to go
that unit's trained so if that company
Commander doesn't have character or like
you said with the little nitpicking
where they're doing like one little
decision that that doesn't align with
their conscience at a time
you know that can build up to the point
where you have a company Commander that
hey you know if I stand up and say hey
we are not trained and I'm gonna get
chewed up on my boss and it's going to
negatively impact my career
you know maybe they're going to take the
easy out and say hey we're trained and
that happens at every single level of
command
and that's why characters are so
important uh well I would say critical
it's critical and it's also the
foundation of leadership so in the
civilian World character is important
and the military can't function without
it
well that's an interesting point because
I think
this is showing up in many different
Realms because
every system that actually works
has a large degree any complex system
any complex human system that works has
a large degree of discretion built into
it somewhere
and
you know that's because if you try to
write the exact rules of something so
that you can automate it then it will
grind to a halt based on
error terms that were too small to
recognize or
conflicts between multiple values so you
need somebody who knows what the
objective is who can say actually okay
this passes Muster that doesn't
not surprising to find that in the
military because the military has to
function in order for uh us to be made
safe by it
but it also functions in other places
too and
what I'm beginning to understand is that
whatever
force it is that decided on the policy
surrounding covet and I truly don't know
what it is and what it's up to I can see
that it's not good it's not wise it's
very dangerous but I don't know what
it's trying to accomplish
but whatever it is
has taken advantage of the discretion
layer of every system and effectively
decapitated it
it is you it has used people's
discretion against reason right you have
this is the case in journalism is the
case in medicine is the case in
government it's apparently the case in
the military where people's
um discretion has been borrowed oh maybe
the worst place
is in science
right the scientific evidence here is
clear right I mean not perfectly precise
we don't know how dangerous this is but
we know it's far more dangerous uh than
was represented and we know that for
healthy young people the danger of the
treatments is so great compared to the
danger of the disease that there's just
no argument in favor of them
and yet the recommendations come because
of the discretion uh at other layers and
I I my my wife Heather recently
published a piece on her substack
about the fact that science functions on
the honor System which is true but I
think the fact is the honor System Finds
Its way into everything that works and
the honor System has been captured right
people are dishonoring themselves by
saying things that they should know
aren't true and that is resulting in uh
well it is it is resulting in
a slow unfolding of you know at the very
least the inversion of Nuremberg and
hopefully not but perhaps worse
um Jordan I know you um
you have been clear about the fact that
there might be although the focus on the
so-called vaccines is understandable
because the level of intrusion is so
great that these are not the only
mandates and I believe if I'm correct uh
your story actually initially unfolded
around uh other mandates is that right
yes um and I think uh if you actually
look at the timeline of you know covid
and and what's transpired since then you
can see that all of this was you know in
my opinion intentionally
um conducted to demoralize people
um specifically in the military you know
we were told that we had to mask up
um even when the civilian uh population
you know was told they didn't have to
wear masks anymore we were told we have
to mask up no matter what and I worked
in a unit with
you know we did shift work and it was
very mentally
um tough situations uh it was a head
unit so processing exploitation
dissemination you're looking at things
that you know most people will never see
in their life
and these are you know young Airmen out
of high school so 18 to 25 year olds
witnessing really traumatic things and
add on the fact that you know they were
put in forced isolation forced
quarantine forced to test to submit to
testing if they wanted to get seen at a
medical clinic and then they were told
to mask up all the time
um they in fact I I knew flight
commanders who would yell at Airmen if
they even put their mask down to to eat
or to breathe I was not one of those
commanders and I very rarely wore my
mask especially if I was you know by
myself and the only time I wore it was
in my job I didn't wear it outside of
the military base but you started to see
this breakdown this mental breakdown
from these young Airmen many of whom
experience suicidal ideation
um just in the span of five months I had
four to five young Airmen who had
experienced suicidal ideation
um suicidal thoughts and when I brought
this up to my chain of command and said
you know the rate of suicides is much
higher than the rate of healthy military
members dying from covid they completely
ignored what I had to say or some of
them said I know but we have to do this
basically I know but we have to follow
these orders
um no matter the you know the science
behind it
um so then after this
um was the code mandates and at this
point I think a lot of people in the
military gave in to these mandates
because they saw that nobody was
sticking up for them with the mass
mandates and they were completely
demoralized and even today you know
military installations are forcing the
unvaccinated to submit to weekly testing
with an eua product
um because they're unvaccinated even if
they have no symptoms with an eua
product that frankly doesn't work right
right so it's it to me
ineptitude doesn't quite get you there
that this is just punishment this is
harassment of people who have shown a
willingness to refuse an immoral order
right and instead of you know backing
off and saying we were wrong you know
we've done evaluation now the science is
showing us you know what we didn't know
before
um they're doubling down and I think
that's the most concerning for me um
specifically and I think for a lot of
Military Officers and Military senior
ncos what was the most concerning was
when you saw the civilian population
being mandated to get a vaccine
um you know in the military it's
expected of us we are expected to get
you know certain vaccines but there's
always been exceptions right there's
always been medical exceptions there's
always been religious accommodation
exceptions
um but when you see the civilian
population being told that in order to
keep your job you have to get a vaccine
for me that was kind of the moment of
what am I doing you know the role of I
think the military is to protect
constitutional rights of Americans and
when when we couldn't even protect
Americans constitutional rights against
our own government that was kind of my
what is going on moment
yeah there are a number of things in
there that I I think we need to focus on
one of them is
okay there are some vaccines that are
required there are reasons for that in
this case you're dealing with something
so new that it has not been FDA approved
so this is a place where informed
consent is essential
it is obviously absent and worse
it is not as if there isn't an approved
version but somehow it's not available
to anybody I am I correct the military
does not have the availability of the uh
the FDA approved version of this vaccine
you are absolutely correct and they have
you know tried to say that they have the
FDA approved version
um but some amazing whistleblowers have
actually exposed that this FDA version
that the DoD said that they had was not
produced at an FDA approved facility
um and so oh sorry go on oh go ahead I
was going to say um and so previously
talking about what's the objective here
I think the objective is to comply with
government mandates because all other
remedies have been completely ignored
um you know hydroxychloroquine is a
remedy that works and in the military
um it's actually something that that's
prescribed if you deploy to African
countries but for some reason the
military would not give you
hydroxychloroquine as a remedy for covid
and so you know you have to kind of
think like what is the objective here is
it to to force vaccinate everybody or is
it government compliance and I think
that there's been a couple of different
mandates that the objective is to comply
with what the government is telling you
right now this worries me tremendously
because the argument I've made is if you
wanted to create a force that would
accept immoral orders this would be how
you would do it you would deliver some
orders that were completely arbitrary
and absurd and then you would see who
showed signs of resistance you would
strong arm them and coerce them and you
would see who would knuckle under and
then anybody who in the face of that
stood strong you'd throw them out right
that's that's basically the rapid plan
to making a compliant force that doesn't
have any uh
any notion of what was learned at
Nuremberg
so that this alarms me it does have the
sense of some
um deadly game of Simon Says
and the result of that is going to be oh
my God our military force is now
um
compliant irrespective of what it is
that it's being told to do
um I I don't want to live in a country
where that's true because I know what
happens in countries where that's true
um so you know maybe
we have to be worried yep go ahead yeah
I don't want to live in that country
either which is why I'm doing what I'm
doing
um you know
Jordan alluded to this earlier but we
have a spiritual crisis going on in the
military and this is just one part of it
when I say spiritual a lot of people
don't know what that means I'm just
using the holistic health and fitness
term for Spiritual it's one of the five
domains of Readiness it's just purpose
what's your purpose
you know I can tell you that my
professional purpose I have a lot of
personal
things that are you know my purpose like
taking care of my family but my
professional purpose is to support and
defend the Constitution
very straightforward and so if I see an
order and a process where there's a
constitutional process in religious
accommodation I see that process not
being respected the number one way that
I can fulfill that purpose is by going
through that process and trying to hold
people accountable and taking that
process seriously and what you saw with
this mandate specifically with religious
accommodations is widespread attempts to
prevent people from submitting religious
accommodations I can tell you that
personally when I talk to chaplains they
would say oh you know that doesn't sound
like a religious belief and then they
would say oh you know just so you know
there haven't been any that have been
approved you know I got told that by at
least a half a dozen individuals you
know those exact words hey just so you
know none have been approved and that
was during a time when none had really
been denied either
and you know I knew the background of
the process from you know following
Robert Barnes who's you know a great
attorney that knows a lot about
constitutional law so I had that benefit
but what about Junior privates that had
no idea you know when they publish a
document that goes through a list of
faiths like hey this is what this one
you know the Pope says this is what this
person that's a Baptist says and they're
saying hey you should be able to get the
shot
um that's coercion that's trying to
insinuate that somebody that that comes
from those faiths doesn't have a
legitimate uh claim and I will tell you
I am an atheist and I have a sincerely
held belief as determined by a chaplain
and so if you understand what
constitutes a religious belief under the
law
then you can understand that almost
everybody that denied this this uh
injection
had a legitimate claim and we actually
have a process in the Army for
uncovering that so not getting this
injection when it ends your career and
exposes you to a lot of adverse action
and unpleasant interpersonal
interactions
why would you make a sacrifice like that
just because you don't want to well you
know in the Army we have something
called Master resiliency training and
there's a bunch of you know divisions of
competencies and one of those
competencies is self-awareness now this
is based on positive psychology research
at the University of Pennsylvania it's
an excellent program and if people just
use the tools that we had and gone okay
let's let's think about this there's a
skill called detect icebergs so hey you
have a soldier they're decline in the
vaccine instead of just saying they're a
dirt bag and assassinating their
character
why not try and figure out why
maybe they can't articulate exactly why
but it's your duty as a leader given
that we're talking about constitutional
rights here your first amendment rights
to dig in and find out exactly why and
if people had just done this and
followed the process it wouldn't have
had nearly the negative impact that it
had you know because there would have
been this way for people that had a
sincere objection to find out hey does
this constitute a religious belief or
not you know there's ways to investigate
that I believe that the services made a
deliberate effort to obfuscate that and
there's evidence of that where you know
an attorney for the Department of
Justice was caught on tape talking about
how oh you know people that are
declining it because it has aborted
fetal stem cells in the testing process
that's going to be a really hard claim
to overcome as if they're strategizing
about how they're going to infringe upon
people's religious freedoms and so you
know that that's my big
thing that I want people to understand
is that by not getting the vaccine or
requesting religious accommodation or
getting the vaccine and taking care of
soldiers and cert you know Airmen what
whatever branch of service by taking
care of them and trying to
you know detect those icebergs see what
those beliefs were to see if they had a
belief that would warrant accommodation
uh I think that we'd be in a really
great place but they just they didn't do
that and I think that at the highest
levels that lack of attention was
encouraged and the focus instead of
being on the Constitution and religious
liberty and First Amendment rights I
think it was exactly like you said I
think it was on compliance I think that
our senior leaders are more concerned
about compliance than they are uh with
fulfilling their Oaths to support and
defend the Constitution which is a
spiritual crisis because I think if you
wear the uniform that should be your
number one purpose professionally
because that's what your oath says it
should be
yeah this has the
unmistakable sense to me at least
of a desire to unhook the normal
constitutional protections right it's
not a question of them failing to meet
them it's a question of them seeing that
a sincere uh religious objection to a
mandated treatment is a loophole that
they cannot tolerate if they you know
basically if you want to have a force
that must comply and is devoid of people
who would resist then you can't have
loopholes like sincerely held religious
beliefs
and I would also say I don't describe
myself as an atheist I'm pretty close to
it I I believe that the universe
um is a place in which there aren't
there is nothing
um metaphysical going on but it doesn't
matter I don't think of myself as an
atheist I think of
um religious beliefs is very important
and fundamental to how we got here but
this is more or less beside the point I
studied
as a scientist that's what I am and I
can tell you that
people's
concerns their religious concerns about
these treatments even if they cannot
phrase it in scientific terms are valid
there is something there is a violation
of a fundamental principle
that you know I can come close to
stating I can say look
you've got a virus it is itself
apparently unnatural
you have a essentially miraculous system
for fending off pathogens that your
ancestors have never encountered before
and it works very well with covid it
works very well with covid and the only
exceptions are people who are profoundly
compromised by either age or
comorbidities or both
the idea that some entity wants to
mandate a radical
physiological alteration of your system
it wants to hijack your cells and turn
them into vaccine factories something
that has never been done before
that it thinks it has the right to tell
you that that is not only in your best
interest but it is so essential to your
functioning uh in the military that it
can require it of you is
Preposterous it's biologically
Preposterous you have a system to fight
off viruses even ones you've never seen
it works well with respect to covid the
mandates are not coherent in light of
that fact in light of the seriousness of
the disease and the uncertainties
surrounding the treatment so okay
those are sentences I can say because I
I trained to be able to phrase it but
the fact that somebody's objection may
come in metaphorical or spiritual terms
does not mean it's not valid their
intuition that hey I don't want that
thing injected into me that sounds like
a violation of my of my nature as a
human whether that nature as a human is
the result of a Creator or the result of
evolution or the result of a Creator who
used Evolution doesn't matter
it's a violation of your humanity and so
I guess the point is those those
objections
are sound
the system that looks at them and says
oh
we can't really tolerate sound
objections now can we because we're
going to be
ordering people to do all kinds of
things that they might object to and so
let's let's deal with that now that's a
system that is uh it's gearing up for
something and
um we can't afford to find out what
frankly
um it is clearly
um on the move
now before we lose it though oh go ahead
wait I was just gonna say you know I've
talked with a lot of members and the way
we feel about it is you know the
government is trespassing on our bodies
on our bodily autonomy
um and so it feels like it's not just
you know a violation
um mentally and spiritually but
physically I mean the government is is
telling us that they have the right to
trespass on us
um
what you have just said
is literally true
right the the mechanism of action here
for these mRNA vaccines
is
to introduce into you something which is
a clumsy pseudo-virus
which enters cells
indiscriminately
and hijacks their Machinery in a way
that is far more durable than we were
led to understand
and the problem
is
your body has one and only one way to
understand cells that are making
proteins that you yourself are not
supposed to make
your body understands those cells as
virally infected and it rightly targets
them for Destruction if those cells are
in your heart and your own immune system
says goodness those are virally infected
cells virally infected cells in one's
heart are a lethal Hazard so as as bad
as it is to destroy your own heart cells
it's better than the alternative right
this is an invasion of your body it's an
invasion of your body by something that
is
um
highly bioactive and intersects your
ancient evolutionary mechanisms in a way
that cannot possibly be safe
so
you know I I think people have too much
comfort
dismissing objections that sound
imprecise this is this is you
trespassing on my body but to my ears
that is a completely accurate
description of what's taking place and
the objection to me is so clear in the
case of
you know they're trespassing for reasons
that they themselves cannot even explain
right if it doesn't prevent contraction
and transmission then why is it their
business is that to save you from
serious harms of covid because the data
on that is clear too you're in an
excellent position to fend off covid if
you're young and healthy and these uh
these shots are not a contributor to
that to that protection so
where do they get off telling you to
take these things it's just it's not
it's not logically coherent in in any
regard
well I'll tell you what they do Brett
they just assert
that it's for readiness
you know unilaterally they don't provide
any data you know hey this is for
Readiness and one of the main reasons
that I'm wanting to speak out and
discuss this issue
is you know I think of the Milgram
experiment and I think about the few
people that didn't keep increasing the
shocks
and who were some of those people they
were people that were electrical
engineers that were familiar
with what that entailed and what was
safe and what it means
and
I'm an expert in Readiness you know you
can say that there's people that maybe
know a little bit more than me but you
know by any account I am an expert in
holistic health and fitness you know
there are not very many division
holistic health and fitness officers
it's a new program I've been in the
military for 12 years
and you know I've seen it from the line
being an infantryman
um and the medical side
I know what Readiness is I know what
what makes it up what it's constituted
of and I will tell you that this mandate
has been a disaster for readiness that's
my opinion
you know and and a lot of the people
that are saying hey you know what it's
for Readiness they're commanders that
don't have uh any medical experience
they don't have any scientific
experience you know I'm a clinician
scientist
and I had excellent training
and you know from my perspective using
you know the kind of reasoning that you
outlined
you you Bayesian inference right you
understand biology so you can you don't
just look at a randomized controlled
trial and say oh yeah this is this is
how it is like you you think of the
prior probability of How likely it is
that a novel you know injection based on
a novel platform
for a novel virus
um for retrovirus that mutates rapidly
you know for a type of virus a
coronavirus that has never been
successfully vaccinated against before
and you go huh I think regardless of
what this randomized controlled style
says you know I'm going to want to see
probably more than one RCT I'm going to
want to see some more more data and in
terms of Readiness there's a lot of
stuff that you can't measure this the
spiritual piece and I'm telling you off
the backs of coming out of Afghanistan
for two decades people that have
sacrificed Untold
on you know Untold hours years
of their lives lost friends and loved
ones
and and to turn around and go into this
where people are you know forced to wear
masks even though they believe in their
hearts that they don't have an effect
forced to take vaccines that they don't
believe have an effect that takes a toll
on Readiness and that spiritual toll is
being discounted as if it's not worth
anything and it's definitely a part of
the picture and I know that your
position and I agree with your position
that on the physical side for young and
healthy population that it's also not
great but even without acknowledging
that and going into that which is
there's still some controversy there I
just want that spiritual piece to be
discussed and to be recognized as a part
of the crisis that we're dealing with
and you see it reflected in recruiting
and retention numbers and they're
everybody's kind of throwing up their
hands and going oh wow I don't know why
this is going on and you know I'll tell
you this is a hypothesis this is my
hypothesis this is what's going on it's
a spiritual crisis and people don't know
uh what their purpose is when when
they're wearing uniform they don't know
why they're here they don't know why
they need to work hard on their Fitness
to work out eat right get their sleep
why would you have the motivation to do
all those things if you're just kind of
mailing it in until you get to
retirement or just trying to survive
until you finish up your first
Enlistment
well we could unpack that for a full
podcast easily
I think part of the problem I I find no
question that the um
the demoralization of the force amounts
to a spiritual crisis for sure and that
will have impacts on Readiness that are
going to be
um
hard to measure right what role does it
play in uh Recruitment and Retention you
know that's a hard you could study it
but it's not going to be obvious you're
not going to know why people don't show
up at your Recruiting office but
um
it's certainly going to play a role but
at the very least we can say
that for anyone
to look you in the eye and tell you that
these mandates are
there for the purpose of readiness
it's like
um
it's like somebody lighting a house on
fire and you say why are you doing that
and they say I'm remodeling right it
doesn't make any sense you've got
mandates that are forcing them to
discharge highly trained people Pilots
right pilots and who we've invested
millions of dollars you're going to
compromise the cardiac health of people
who are flying around Jets worth many
millions of dollars those Pilots ability
to endure stress in actual battle
is dependent on their heart health and
the safety of the nation may be
dependent on their ability to do that
job all of these things impact Readiness
in a disastrous way so the idea that
this is about readiness just couldn't
possibly be more ironic this is making
us much less ready and
you know I said in the the first episode
with with military folks
that I don't I try to tread very
carefully around issues of conspiracy I
don't believe in advancing conspiracy
theories I believe in talking about
hypotheses that's that's what I do as a
scientist but the problem is that the
absurdity of claims around readiness
when you are claiming to make the force
more ready as you are very directly
making it less ready
that sounds worse than incompetent that
does not sound like an error that sounds
like something that our enemies might
want us to do right it's far better
rather than face our military on the
battlefield to get us to hobble it right
that sounds like enemy action and I'm
completely open to here and I will be in
some ways relieved to discover that this
isn't somehow our enemy is causing us to
destroy the force that protects us but
it is at least a hypothesis that belongs
on the table right these are very
unreasonable things that a country that
wished to last you know another couple
hundred years would not mess with our
Readiness in this way
um and I I guess I guess I'm hoping that
somebody will hear me say that and
they'll say you know Brett as bad as
this is here's an explanation that uh
establishes this is not our enemies this
is this is something gone wrong internal
to our system but but I'll Advance a
more charitable hypothesis and it's just
that you know there's a scientific
technocratic Elite that really believes
that this stuff works they think that
you can
you know they really believe it they
really believe hey if we have
centralized control you know we have the
experts that you know are the best
educated they come from Ivy League
schools we get them into the positions
where they can make the decisions and
you know everybody else is too stupid to
make decisions for themselves and so we
need that power and authority in order
to do that to make the world a better
place and maybe they recognize at this
point that they were wrong with this
particular issue but that concept needs
to be defended you know that regardless
of you know the risk benefit analysis
for young healthy service members for
this particular injection you know down
the road the the scientific technocratic
leader are going to come up with the
next great thing and they need people to
comply because otherwise you know we'll
never make it as a as a species
well I have to say
uh I don't believe that hypothesis is
likely I will say the beauty of speaking
in terms of hypotheses it tells us
exactly what the rules of engagement are
that hypothesis makes predictions and
unfortunately they're not easy ones for
us to test but I would say if these
people really believe this garbage then
they're first in line for these shots
and I would bet strongly in the other
direction I think they are mandating
things for other people and they have
all kinds of explanations for why they
themselves are doing something else now
I know that publicly they will represent
themselves as uh
as accepting the treatments but
um hopefully someday we'll know
yeah I think it's even more than what
Grant was saying because it's not you
know the destruction really of the
military didn't start with these vaccine
mandates I mean it started with critical
race Theory it started with demoralizing
the force and making this lose sight of
our military identity and focus on
things that make us different
individually and I think the most
disheartening uh one of the most
disheartening aspects of what I've
witnessed in the military is that I've
believed you know that the military is a
Force for good and I think most everyone
does and I still believe that but when
we witnessed this coercion this abuse
these unlawful orders and we voiced our
concerns up the chain of command you
know nobody listened to us or very few
people listen to us and we had to go
outside of our own chain of command and
the only reason why over a hundred
thousand military members are still you
know fighting and have their job today
is not because the chain of command
realized what they did was wrong it's
because of the court systems it's
because the court systems put
injunctions in place and I hope that
people understand you know the severity
of that the fact that military members
had to go outside of the military system
and find attorneys to represent us and
usually what happens is you know there's
the UCMJ there's the court systems
within the military there are remedies
in place within our chain of command and
we could not get anybody to listen to us
so that is a very significant
um you know fact that I think people
need to understand is that there are
people fighting within the military
against our own chain of command because
we believe so strongly in our oath of
office in our oath to the Constitution
and in protecting constitutional rights
for all Americans yeah I think this is
this is a crucial Point
um that
uh
you have a higher obligation the chain
of command is a mechanism but your
obligation is to something higher in the
case of Military Officers it is to the
Constitution and therefore to the nation
and its well-being and to the extent
that the chain of command is saying
utterly absurd and dangerous things
you're obligated to fight it as
difficult as that is
[Music]
um
I do want to say I can imagine a world I
want to live in a world where
the military because it is interested in
the long-term well-being of the nation
uh and frankly the world
that it does own up to what it's gotten
wrong right how relieved would we be to
hear it say you know what here's why we
made the error and uh we put people in
Jeopardy lives were lost uh it is in all
of our interests to correct the policy
as quickly as possible so no more lives
are lost right that would I think be a
tremendous boost to morale and therefore
a boost to Readiness but we see the
opposite
um and that you know I realized in in
listening to you earlier Jordan
um you were talking about face masks and
the mandates and the fact that those
mandates have implications which I think
uh go to in part what Grant is talking
about that the human face is a highly
unique product of evolution right our
ability to exchange emotional
information with our faces is
unparalleled and it's there for a reason
and these masks yes they have a symbolic
uh relevance they they function as a
kind of gag an anonymizer a confuser of
emotional information but you know they
directly interfere with our
relationships with each other now here's
the connection though
I got the mask thing dead wrong
I was very early on masks in fact I was
so early on self masking as the
information about covid was emerging
that uh I got the nickname at the
hardware store that I frequent as the
Bandit because I was coming into the
hardware store in a bandana before
anybody was wearing masks right because
I thought this is bound to be helpful
this is a dangerous virus which I still
believe
and uh I thought you know I was modeling
the behavior that I thought was right as
the evidence came in that uh
masks are mostly useless and cloth masks
especially so
I acknowledge my error I said look I had
it wrong
here's why I think I had it wrong
and I don't advise you to wear these
things and in fact I'm now concerned
that we're doing thing you know we're
putting them on children which is bound
to interfere with their normal
psychological development and their
ability to interrelate with each other
and their ability to understand adults
and their ability to develop a sense of
irony and all of these important human
characteristics are interfered with by
masks so you know did I like being wrong
about masks no it was embarrassing but
it's not half as embarrassing as staying
wrong or Worse pretending that I hadn't
gotten it wrong right and just changing
my behavior and hoping nobody noticed so
you know I it seems to me the lesson is
clear right adults part of being an
adult is recognizing that you've made an
error acknowledging it so that errors
are reduced in the future both your own
errors and other people's errors and uh
the government and the military are
doing the exact opposite they are not
behaving in an adult fashion which
raises all sorts of questions
Brad I think on that note for
you know being able to recognize that
you're wrong you can't even get there if
you don't act in accordance with what
you believe
so I think one of the biggest problems
that we have is that people are afraid
you know they believe something
and they're afraid to verbalize that or
behave in accordance with what they
believe
and you're not going to be right every
time if you do that but you know to use
another landmark psychology study like I
always think of the ash Conformity
experiment
you know like if you think the lines are
different lengths say so you know and
then look stupid and then apologize and
change your minds but you'll never be
able to learn and you'll never be able
to do your your duty to the organization
especially when it comes to solving
complex problems
and being able to get out of groupthink
if you don't say what you think and what
you believe and lay it out as you
understand it let other people test your
reasoning and give you feedback and you
know assume the risk that you're going
to be wrong because we're all going to
be wrong at some point we're human to
errors to human or to air is to be human
so
um I think that that like you said
nothing's better uh A Better Learning
opportunity than making a mistake and
then being able to recognize that and
and change your mind but nobody's
getting those opportunities because
they're so terrified to say anything
that's outside of you know
you know the Overton window
which goes to uh the earlier part of our
discussion
um about the
the way that people are dissuaded from
learning this lesson is they are
punished if they show signs of learning
right so I think we have to acknowledge
that
um I mean let's face facts the reason
that I'm doing the Dark Horse podcast
is that I stood up and said what needed
to be said about wokeness when it took
over the college that I was very happily
teaching at and that my wife was very
happily teaching at
I don't work there anymore
right I couldn't stay in my job the job
that I had very happily done for 14
years very successfully done for 14
years a job I felt great about
I had to find something else to do
because it became impossible to continue
in my role
Jordan it sounds like that's your
experience in the military so it's not
surprising
that people who look at the costs which
have been artificially driven through
the roof for doing the right thing for
acknowledging that you got something
wrong it is not surprising to me that
people look at those costs and decide
not to pay them and in fact
you know I can't even really judge
people who decide not to pay those costs
because look I'm fortunate I was able to
move from that job and to do something
else that keeps a roof over my family's
head
but not everybody's in that position a
lot of people are in a much more
insecure position to begin with and so
the ability of these coercive systems to
punish them into compliance is that much
greater
um
and the hard part about this is
what really makes it safer if we want to
drive the costs of doing the right thing
down the way to do that is for more of
us to stand up but because these forces
have such disproportionate influence
over us they can dissuade each
individual from standing up and
therefore there's no chorus of people
standing up and that chorus is therefore
not in a position to make it safer for
other people who are more insecure
financially or in whatever other way to
stand up so
at some level this all comes down to a
massive power asymmetry right what is
right is not unclear at this point right
many of us got stuff wrong early in
covid but by now the information is
there for people to Simply evaluate the
evidence
and reach a reasonable conclusion but so
many people have said and done things
along the way and the cost of bailing
themselves out has been uh artificially
Amplified specifically so that they will
not say what they now either do or
should know
and let's just agree that that's at the
very least an actually difficult puzzle
to solve
all right yeah I absolutely agree that
it's difficult but you know we all have
different values and you know for me
personally self-expression
you know I don't think we have a country
if we lose the First Amendment
you know if we don't have the ability to
express ourselves uh we don't have an
America and you know
I I don't think that there's any cost
too high uh to pay in order to be able
to express yourself
um and I'm I'm prepared to face any
consequences with respect to that you
know I this might sound dorky but I
think about you know the speech in
Braveheart you know it's like yeah you
know stay quiet
you know you'll live and you know many
years from now laying in your bed
you know you'll think
you could have said you could have stood
up and you could have spoken your mind
and maybe it would have worked out and
on that note look at what's happened
with Dr Sam sigalov you know they he has
been a very vocal uh proponent of
taking a an honest look at these
injections
and they came after his license for it
as a physician
and recently he just got his clinical
privileges reinstated
so a lot of it is an illusion a lot of
it is based on fear and I think a lot of
people might be surprised as to the
degree to which if you are speaking from
the heart
and you're saying what you believe to be
true
uh you know then it's totally
unreasonable for people to try and ruin
your lives about that and in fact when
people try to ruin your life
or take adverse action against you from
speaking your mind and speaking your
heart
it empowers our side in this struggle uh
towards freedom of Destruction in in
America and American values
yeah
I'm struck
you know in the circles that I travel in
there's a
you know we've all heard it people will
say is that a hill you want to die on
and I have a complex relationship with
that uh particular formulation because
my sense is
there are Hills I'll die on
I don't want to die on them that's not
my intent but the point is the real
question is do you believe
that there are Hills that are worth
risking your life over
and our military
by its very nature
is composed or needs to be composed of
people who agree that there are Hills
worth dying on and I would say
two of them are easy to name
one of them is Nuremberg Hill and the
other is Constitution hell and the fact
that these Hills are now threatened
because individuals are being dissuaded
from thinking those are Hills worth
dying on is itself it's almost a
separate threat here right we are being
trained to believe that our own
individual well-being is so important
that these abstractions you know
Nuremberg and the Constitution are
secondary to them
nothing could be further than from the
truth because in fact
you know we are the custodians of
something
uh incredibly immeasurably valuable
right we are custodians of America we
are custodians of the West we are
custodians of the Earth
we are custodians of the human lineage
all of these things
are bigger than we are and all of them
are threatened if we allow these forces
to uh train us to accept obviously wrong
things to agree to orders that are
obviously immoral all of those things
are jeopardized so really I I have to
wonder who looks at issues this big and
doesn't realize actually you know what
I'm not looking to die on any Hill but
if I've got a die on one that's that's a
reasonable choice right who doesn't see
that
many military leaders have asked many
people I know you know and I've gotten
the question myself
is this the hill that you want to die on
and those leaders asking that question
they will never find that Hill
if this is not it they will never find
that Hill
yeah yeah if if this ain't that if kovid
doesn't reveal all of these Hills and
the need to protect them I don't know
what does it seems that clear Jordan go
on yeah I've been asked that same
question and you know I think a question
that I have and that many military
members have is where is the moral
courage of our commanders and I have
been told in you know confidence by many
military members
um that they're rooting for me that
they're rooting for us that they wish
that they could you know join us
um and it it's been very eye-opening for
me because the majority of those
comments come from men who who got the
vaccine
um that maybe did it sacrificially for
their family to provide for their family
but others did it because it was just
easier to to give in and to submit to
this than to fight
um and so for me you know I look at that
in the state of our military and I think
where is the moral courage you know
where are the commanders and Lieutenant
Colonel long has said this where where
are the Mighty Men of Courage
um and I think that the military and the
government did such a great job
isolating people and making people think
that they were alone that you know their
um thoughts on not getting this were
crazy and that they were wrong they did
such a good job of it that so many
people gave in and have to now sit with
that and feel you know that they gave
them they gave up their bodily autonomy
for a lie
um and so I think you know it's never
too late to stand up and say you know we
were wrong
um but I think a lot of military members
feel completely betrayed betrayed by
their commanders betrayed by the chain
of command betrayed by the country we
swore you know to protect that we would
die for
um and that has been very
um disappointing you know I I hear
testimony in parents of service members
reach out to me all the time and say you
know all my son wanted to do his entire
life was be a marine and serve this
country and now he's discharged for not
getting an eua vaccine and he has a less
than honorable discharge
characterization and can't even get a
job
um and so it's really breaking down this
patriotic you know element of Americans
and this is going to have you know you
talked about the mask mandates and how
detrimental it will be for children this
is going to have generational effects
um on the Readiness for our military
yeah profound effects that are going to
last for Generations uh if
something something honorable doesn't
gain control of the system and and uh
start uh for riding the ship
I will tell you I'm a little bit chilled
to hear that your experience has been of
people quietly personally approaching
you and saying that they're rooting for
you while they're not standing up
because I have had that experience more
than once
um most profoundly
when Heather and I stood up against the
uh the woke Revolution at Evergreen
many people especially colleagues
came to us privately and said you're
right but refuse to say anything
publicly they allowed it to happen to us
and
in that context
you know I came to some conclusions I
didn't want to come to
I realized that Academia selects for
cowardice and that there is an epidemic
of cowardice in Academia as a result
but it's quite another thing to discover
that the epidemic of cowardice is also
afflicting the military
right it's one thing for people to get
things wrong maybe to be coerced into
thinking wrongly about them it's another
thing for people to know better in the
military and not have the courage to say
what they know that really speaks to a
force that is not going to be ready to
make the kind of sacrifices in battle
that one must make
so
uh it's alarming for me to hear that I
can't be surprised because it was one of
the most painful lessons these crises
they reveal character and to the extent
that
um that cowardice compromises people's
character boy do these crises reveal
where it exists but it's riddled
throughout our military that's that's a
scary shock
the parallels are are uncanny and I will
tell you you are one of my Inspirations
for standing up you know when I when I
heard about
initially read about what you went
through
you know you're one of of several people
that have been in a situation that I can
empathize with and you know I thought to
myself when I read it I was like if I
was in that position
I you know
I would do I would have done the same
thing
and you can't tell yourself something
like that
when you're confronted so like I kind of
look at this as an opportunity
uh for all of us and you know what it
has been a an opportunity in a lot of
ways because it has connected me
with some of the most amazing Americans
I've ever met you know including Jordan
uh and you know I feel like these people
are going to be lifelong friends and
brothers and sisters in arms
and
you know this situation has provided
a litmus test you know that has allowed
us to separate the wheat from the chaff
and and separate the people who uh you
know talk the talk and the people that
can walk the walk and you know you are
among the people in my life and your
story and what you went through and the
unbelievable pressure because you mean
you had somebody in your face
um you know and there are some of my
colleagues in this vaccine con mandate
context that had the same thing happen
but you know you know I I just felt
compelled to say that because it's true
you know your story and the stories of
people like you inspired uh me to have
the moral courage to do what I think is
right and I think that you know what Sam
sigalov likes to say he has it in his
signature block his courage is
contagious and so you know same deal
with him and Teresa long like those are
individuals that I talk to that that
gave me motivation to uh begin speaking
my mind
well that's very nice to hear it's a
little uncomfortable but let's let's use
it actually because I think I can mine
my own experience a little bit to figure
out
um
what it all what it ought to imply to
others who are trying to figure out what
to do one thing I will say is that your
uh your description of having been put
in contact with
um extremely high quality people people
of excellent character
this is what happens when you do the
difficult thing and you stand up right I
have lost so many friends but the
upgrade in the quality of my
interactions has been equally
spectacular it's very painful to lose
the friends the ones who don't stand by
you and disappoint you
the people who become your friends when
you've stood up together
are remarkable and so if you focus on
who you're going to lose it'll keep you
from doing the right thing if you
recognize well
um
something fascinating happens to people
who jump that Gap I promise it does
um
so I also wanted to say uh
people often talk to me about what
happened at Evergreen and I sometimes
here in what they say
that they think they think highly of me
because of the choice I made and that
really was not the experience and I I
think there are some breadcrumbs here
that people can follow
I never for a moment thought I had a
choice
right I literally I put myself back in
the situation
and I think
I just don't have access to the Circuit
that would have done something different
in that case and I'm glad for that right
it's lucky for me not having a choice in
that situation is wonderful because you
won't screw it up right I don't know why
I ended up that way but
I I guess I'm hoping
that we will recognize that that that is
what a military is supposed to be right
a military is supposed to be composed of
people who uh their character and their
training results in them not blinking at
the point that they have to act right
that's a not a natural state it's a
difficult state to attain but the the
defense of the nation and and our
principles depends on it and to the
extent that whatever our military has
become has compromised that unflinching
nature uh it's time for a rethink right
um so anyway thank you for saying what
you said I appreciate it uh
not having a choice uh means that some
of it is not deserved I think because
you know Brett that's what living in the
spirit is you know in the in the Pauline
Christian context being justified
like that's what living in the spirit is
you know you you know what the right
thing to do is and you don't have a
choice
so I mean that just
it's
it's an exemplification of spiritual
enlightenment you know and I'm not
blowing smoke you know that's that's
just how it is and that's the way that I
conceive of it anyways
yeah I think I think that's good and I
wonder
um you know it's funny you describe
yourself as an atheist and I'm I'm
pretty close to one and and yet uh the
terms you're using to to describe where
those characteristics come from
borrow from a whole other language
um but I do think
uh what I experienced you know if I'm
honest with myself the reason that I'm
wired that way has to do with the fact
that
um
you know
I don't mean this psychologically but
I was very secure so that I wasn't yes I
loved my job but I didn't need it
right I I had skills I could go do
something else I had a family that
wasn't going to look at scans at me if
uh things didn't go well
and so anyway the the reason I raise it
is
I am very very careful not to judge
people who
can't find their way there because in
many of their cases their Baseline is
just far more vulnerable right
so and this actually goes to something
that you were alluding to Jordan
actually both of you have alluded to
this
um
the there is a kind of a Cascade
is you say uh grant that courage is
contagious
we've seen this I think we've all seen
it but the point is those of us who are
in a position to say the right thing
early make it safer for the next rung
you know people who are just somewhat
less secure than we are they can say the
right thing and they make it safer for
people who are just a little bit less
secure than they are and that is how
that contagiousness can actually
um turn the tide is if each of us can
muster the courage that is possible from
our level of
security
to generate safety for others you know
we can bootstrap enough safety to make
the system do the courageous thing and
that uh
um at the moment I'm not especially
hopeful based on what I've seen but uh I
certainly uh
that is my wish is that that that
happens quickly
yes and actually that's something that
we talk about is you know the the thing
that is keeping the dod from mandating
these boosters is this line of defense
that we have formed
um by by pushing back on the original
mandate and so these people who got it
thinking that they just had to get one
shot or two shot in and it would be done
um I think that a lot of them because
I've heard from people have realized
that it is because so many have stood up
and said this is unlawful and we're not
going to comply we're going to you know
push back against this that is the
reason why booster shots have not been
mandated and I think you know given the
time it's been over a year since the dod
mandate was implemented people are now
awake to what has occurred
um and so you know you talked about
losing friends I hope that they know
that you're not just fighting for
yourself you are fighting for them I
mean I think a lot of people have you
know come to realize that that you know
we are fighting even if we don't agree
with with them
um even if they say you know we're wrong
by not you know protecting our neighbors
and getting the shot we are fighting for
their rights to be able you know when
the next one comes down you know God
forbid but to for them to be able to say
no I'm not going to do this
yeah that's what it is to be a a citizen
of a Nation right we don't fight for you
know those on our side of the political
aisle we fight for the nation as a whole
those who agree with us and those who
disagree with us and I I do feel that
way that you're right to informed
consent uh is uh
sacred whether you intend to exercise it
or just
take the shot because some doctor told
you you should
right
um You have that right whether you
exercise it is your choice but whether
you have it is not you have to have that
right and and so yes we you know we do
fight for even those who uh oppose us
I I did want to I I some part of me
doesn't want to say this but your point
about the boosters not having been
mandated and that being a measure of the
success of the resistance
I see this in the civilian world I
believe we have been very successful at
raising awareness of the um the radical
nature of these vaccines the hazards to
which they expose people the possibility
that there are alternative treatments
the fact that natural and innate
immunity uh are your best defense if
you're young and healthy we've been very
successful at creating that awareness
but
the enemy
uh fears nothing more than that success
and so what it does is it will it will
spend it will bend over backwards to
deny you the evidence of the impact
you've had right it doesn't want others
following that example and it doesn't
want you learning how to do it better
next time so it will pollute the data so
that you can't see your impact it will
it will give credit to something else so
that you will feel that your effort was
wasted and the advice I would give you
and anyone else listening who is in this
battle is don't listen to it right work
backwards from the change in the world
that you can see and you know be careful
don't over extrapolate from the change
but to the extent that people are not
lining up for boosters in the civilian
world and the military is not mandating
them uh that is a strong indication that
what you have been doing is well worth
it
all right is there more that either of
you want to say before we close this out
I would just like to push back a tiny
bit on the consideration of security and
spiritual awareness
uh
when I was put in a position you know 12
years in in a position where I feel like
I'm finally able to make the impact that
I wanted to make
um doing something that I think is
important which is trying to maximize
the human performance of soldiers not
necessarily so that they're more lethal
that's a logical consequence of them
being
healthy and fit
uh and and being able to find their own
purpose and having the skills they need
to achieve that purpose
when I was put in that position a part
of the religious accommodation process
is you go through and you know there are
a bunch of questions on your faith and
then you know detailed questions and
you know reflecting back a lot of us had
suicidal ideation like I did I'm not the
only one and uh but something good can
come of that in in what's called
post-traumatic growth you know so I feel
like I had some
spiritual growth some post-traumatic
spiritual growth
and going through that experience I
would say just like in your in your
position where you said you didn't have
a choice
were you sitting there and thinking
about oh you know actually I'll be okay
if I don't lose my job you weren't
thinking about any of that
it was already done because you had
achieved that level of
Spiritual Awakening where you know what
the right thing to do is and you're
you're gonna do it and you're gonna face
the consequences
and yes some people are in
in positions where if they speak up they
are taking on a higher amount of risk
that is unquestionable and relatively
speaking because I have a professional
degree I'm probably taking on less risk
than say somebody that's a pure combat
arms person with 15 years of service
it's depending on that retirement
but nevertheless
you know that spiritual acknowledgment
of doing the right thing and being
committed to that and accepting the
consequences
it's it's parallel to an outside of a
consideration for the material
consequences of doing the right thing
you know once you commit that that's
what you're going to do and that's the
path that you're on in life and that
you're you'll accept the consequences
like a lot of people if you you know
believe in an afterlife and have
traditional you know religious beliefs I
can make a little bit more sense about
you know heaven and so on and so forth
but for me it's it's life you know what
kind of Life do you want to live and do
you want to truly live while you're
alive and the only way to do that is by
staying true to yourself and if the
consequences of that are incredibly
painful then so be it we don't know the
future we can't know the future it's
always speculative so if you waste
cognitive resources sitting around and
thinking about what could go wrong if
you do the right thing you're not there
yet you know and if you want to get
there you just have to recognize that
you don't know the future and you might
be surprised uh as to what the future
might hold for you if you do the right
thing regardless of uh the consequences
as long as you're doing the right thing
in accordance with what you believe and
know in your heart
that's very well said and you put
something together for me that I hadn't
realized before which is when I say I
had no choice you're right the answer is
I wasn't
none of that was going through my mind
at the time because I had already
decided who I was and what I was going
to do so there was nothing to decide in
that moment which does strike me as
um
you know
a a military mindset right you you train
for it so that when it actually happens
in front of you how you will react is
already you know a settled question
um Jordan did you have anything you
wanted to to say in closing
I just wanted to encourage the audience
you know that the military is still an
institution for good there are still
amazing commanders fighting within the
system and there are many who have like
you stated earlier in the podcast have
come to realize you know that they were
wrong and are working to correct you
know in remedy really what's been going
on
um and I would just ask you know for the
American people to help us by contacting
Representatives you know we're changing
hearts and Minds all the time
um thank you so much for having us on
here to share our testimony and what
we've encountered you know throughout
the last two years really but we need
the help of the American people
um there's a historical number of
lawsuits uh filed by military members
it's never been done before and I think
that that's a testament to how strongly
we fail and we you know and how
convicted we are that we are right and
that we are standing up for our
constitutional rights and the
constitutional rights of all Americans
yeah uh I I think
the opportunity here to return the favor
to a force that protects us from all
sorts of things which we don't have to
think about because they don't threaten
us right a a functional military is
something that up frees US citizens to
do other important things and
uh your Jeopardy is not something we can
allow ourselves to turn away from I will
say I appreciate your
um
thanking me for the opportunity but I
don't I don't see it that way I see this
as
a my obligation to my nation and also my
obligation to people who are threatened
because they
um
because they have honorably signed up to
protect the country and that has exposed
them to a force that has more power over
them than the federal government has
over the rest of us
so in any case I hope that
hearing you and understanding your
mindset what has motivated you to stand
up what you have faced I hope that that
wakes people up not only to your
predicament but to what it suggests
about the moment in history that we all
share
and you know so far
although
covet has revealed many bright spots it
has brought people to public attention
who I truly think are of excellent
character both of you among them
um I also think it has been
a massive
setback for the values that we uh paid
so dearly for
but it would be wonderful if uh that
setback awakened people to the value of
opportunities that they take for granted
and if they
became consciously grateful for them and
acted to protect them the number one way
they can do that is by recognizing uh
that the military mandates are
um
are unjust and must be reversed uh and
anyway I I hope it happens and I I hope
that we have contributed to it happening
here today
thanks so much all right as well Jordan
and Grant oh go ahead and Grant you want
to say something no I just wanted to say
thanks so much for having us it was a
wonderful conversation
well thank you both for doing this and
uh I I very much hope we see positive
change uh as quickly as possible
all right thank you Brett thanks and uh
thanks everybody for watching
[Music]